- I hear we have this in common.
You are a homebody, you
like to be in bed by nine.
- Yes, I actually did not--
- That's me!
- All the work stuff
that happens after that,
I'm like, you're not gonna get much.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] You're not gonna get anything.
- I get glassy-eyed and I
just wanna have my snacks.
Tuck my shirt into my PJs.
- In my PJs, call it a night.
- Yep, call it a night,
get in bed, and do this.
(audience laughing)
- Now I love that, I love that.
And here's the thing I love about you,
you're so normal.
(audience laughing)
When we were at the
AMAs, you were hosting.
And I was like, "Oh my god, I love her."
I'm sitting here going off,
and all of a sudden I'm like,
"Why is Diana Ross getting
onstage with all her family?"
(laughing)
I was like, I had no idea.
- I love that.
- This 2017
(audience laughing)
like that this happened.
And I'm like a fan of
you and I had no idea.
- [Tracee] I love that,
at least my career worked.
- No, you're so good, you're so talented.
- Thank you.
- I had no idea and then
it kinda made sense,
the talent doesn't fall far from the tree,
but I was like, wow.
Then I was like, "You're so normal."
I would have never guessed
that you would have grown up in Hollywood.
I would have guessed you grew up--
- Well I didn't grow up in Hollywood,
I grew up in my mom's house.
(audience laughing)
- Well, okay, okay.
- And we weren't in Hollywood.
We didn't live here,
only when I was little.
- You didn't like go out or anything.
- No, and I mean, my mom is such a mom.
She's a mom before she's anything else.
And so I just had a really--
- [Kelly] That's why you're great!
- Yeah, I had like a
really regular upbringing.
I got a lot of siblings.
You know what I mean?
My mom was always like,
"This money is not for you.
"This money is for me."
- That's me!
- Know what I mean?
- My kids are like, "We have money."
I'm like, "No, sir,
- [Both] "I have money."
(laughing)
- You're broke.
You ain't got any money.
- You didn't do a thing.
- I'm spending all of
this, you better get a job.
- That's exactly what
she used to say to us.
She was like, "I don't
know, you better figure out
"what you're doing."
- I just bought a ranch,
I hope y'all figure it out.
- She's like, "I'll pay
for doctors and make sure
"there's a roof over your
head until a certain point.
"And then go on."
- I'll pay for health and
education, nothing else.
- Yeah, that's it.
- 'Cause you know and
I turned out just fine
and I didn't have anything.
I worked hard, so.
(audience cheering)
I find that amazing, though.
'Cause my big fear as a
parent of having kids,
now we have four kids,
my husband and I grew up
very humble beginnings
and we're always like,
"How do parents do it
"where your kids don't turn out in rehab
"or like something crazy."
- I think it's the value of relationship,
the value of family and
the value of working.
I mean, my mom is hard worker
and I learned all of that from
her by example, not just--
- Pressure, okay, interesting.
- Yeah, you gotta be a good person, Kelly!
- I'm trying, Tracee!
(laughing)
Apparently though I'm not
as good as Quee over there.
Promise's mom is gonna write
a book and help us all out.
Quee's killing me in the
parent department, it's fine.
But you, big news though.
You actually posted the Girlfriends,
you're having a reunion, right?
(audience cheering)
I'm excited, I'm excited!
- You know, "Girlfriends"
ran for eight seasons,
173 episodes, we were
important to so many people,
and it's been 11 years
that we've been off the air
and surreal experience
bringing the Girlfriends
on to "Black-ish", it was
like a merging of worlds.
So, yeah, they are coming on
this season as my girlfriends.
- [Kelly] I love it!
- It was like no time had passed.
I mean the love, the giggles,
- [Kelly] Those are the good friends.
- [Tracee] The chemistry
was like right back,
just right back.
It was amazing.
- Do you, in your personal life,
have those kinda girls too?
- Absolutely, you can't live without them.
- [Kelly] No.
- Oh my god.
- My husband can't stand it,
but I have so many female friends.
- But I feel like a
lot of my best friends,
their husbands know that
their marriage doesn't work
if it's not for the friends.
(laughing)
- You can go, we're still gonna be here.
- But it's like the balance,
you know what I mean?
Like you want me, you want
me to help balance this out.
- You need me.
- You need me, okay.
- And you're welcome.
- Exactly. (laughing)
- I talked her off the ledge.
- Yeah, I have a really good tribe
of incredible girlfriends.
- I think you need that,
like men and women,
you just need that kind of close circle
that you can really just bare all
and be gross in front of
and mean if you wanna just vent, you know?
- And that can see you when
you can't see yourself,
that can ground you.
- Call you out.
- You know, I feel like
one of my best friends
really anchors me to
the best part of myself.
And really my friends are people
that I run things by when I'm scared.
And I have to say, that's
the beauty of text messages,
'cause you can be in a
room full of people having
really awful feelings inside,
that soup of emotions,
and you can text your best
friends and get that shot
of God, of love, of support,
- [Kelly] Humor.
- Of humor without anybody knowing.
And so yeah, my friends are, they're key.
- That's awesome!
So you're executive
producing, is it a spinoff?
- I just love the way
that sounds, I'm so sorry.
(laughing)
- You're an executive producer.
(audience cheering)
And it is, it's awesome.
- It sounds amazing.
- Here's my thing
though, with "Mixed-Ish",
it's a spinoff, it's
your character, right?
- It is a spinoff, it's
my character, a flashback.
So I am not physically--
- [Kelly] Oh like a prequel.
- Yes, it's a prequel.
I am not physically, that sounds
like perfume or something,
I don't know that sounds like--
- Let's come out with it, prequel.
- Okay, yeah, prequel.
So it is a flashback, I'm
not physically on the show,
it is my voice, so it's my voiceover
kind of like "Wonder Years",
remember "Wonder Years"?
- Oh so it's you as a kid, yeah?
- Yes, it's me as a kid.
- Of course I remember "Wonder Years".
- The lovely young girl that is playing me
looks more like me than me.
(laughing)
- I love that.
- Like it's really weird.
I'm like, "Oh my god, you're
me, but you're not me.
"Like I don't understand."
It's so weird.
But she's so great and yes,
it's fish out of water comedy
and it's that story of what
all of us are dealing with
when we're not like
everybody else in the room
and how do you find out who you are
and hold on to that.
- Absolutely, 100%.
(audience clapping)
That's beautiful.
Well you have a new hair
line as well, right?
Yes you do!
This is my favorite thing though,
you've been working on this hair line
for what, 20 years? (laughs)
- 20 years of dreaming,
10 years of working on it.
I wrote my first haircare
brand pitch in 2008
when "Girlfriends" finished
and it's taken me 10
years to make it happen.
- Oh my gosh.
(audience cheering)
- It is for--
- It's a labor of love.
- It is for Promise, it is for me,
it is for curly, coily,
and tight-textured hair.
It is a community of people
that have not been supported
and celebrated in our
beauty and our glory--
- And represented.
- Yes, and we all know
that key is products.
You gotta get products that work,
that hydrate and nourish your hair,
make it healthy and juicy and joyful,
and that's what Pattern,
my haircare products, do.
(audience cheering)
- I love it, I love it!
You're literally one of
my favorite people ever.
We've talked hair, we've talked career,
we've talked family, body.
You have alter egos, though.
- Make it bigger, hold on.
- [Kelly] And I've seen these.
Get it really big.
- Yes!
- Yas!
No, but you have these
alter egos that you do.
And I've only, are there
three, 'cause I've seen three.
- There's actually five,
but you know of three.
- Okay, I've only seen three.
What's the one with the
lips up to here and the--
- Oh, Madame Hiver,
you're dear, sweetheart.
- Oh my god, I love you!
- Yeah, she's a bit of an
alcoholic, there she is.
- [Kelly] That's my favorite!
- Yeah, she's a dear.
(laughing)
You're a dear.
She likes to drink brown alcohol.
- Oh my god, I love it.
Wait, you also have the rapper, right?
- T-Murda.
- [Kelly] Yeah, T-Murda.
Look at her, Quee knows!
- Yeah, T-Murda and then
there's Caliope Champignon
who's a fashion stylist, architect.
And she never speak French,
but she speak English
with a French accent and this is...
- Oh my god, that is so sexy.
I didn't even hear anything,
all I heard was dialect,
it was so pretty, it was so good.
(laughing)
- Yeah, so yes, oui.
- Wow, that's so Meryl Streep!
You just went Meryl Streep on me!
You just like brought
out all these accents!
(audience cheering)
Like I'm like what?
That was so hot!